BRIAN FITZPATRICK:
Good afternoon.
My name is Brian Fitzpatrick,
and most people call me Fitz.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN: And I am
Ben Collins-Sussman, and many
people call me Ben
Collins-Sussman.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: You've
probably seen us doing a lot
of the Ask a Google
Engineer videos.
And we've been giving talks at
Google I/O for the entire
duration of Google I/O
for five years now.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN: And today
we get to interview some
wonderful folks here
at Google I/O 2012.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: And these
guys are actually organizers
of Google Developer Groups
from around the world.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN: I'm very
excited to talk to them and
learn about their experiences by
organizing Google Developer
Communities.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: So let's
get our first guest on.
Come right on in.
Hi, welcome.
What's your name?
BADRI KULKARNI: Hi,
my name is Badri.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: And Badri,
tell us where are you from,
and what do you do?
BADRI KULKARNI: Yeah, sure.
I'm from GDG Bangalore, India.
So I co-organize along with
one of my organizers, GDG
Bangalore chapter.
So we conduct a lot of events
around Google technologies.
So to give you a brief idea
about our GDG chapter and tell
you how GDG helps developers
connect together, so I would
like to share you
my experiences
with a GDG, GDG Bangalore.
So we started a year ago, last
year around September.
So from that point to this
point, we had a lot of events
around Google technologies, some
of them being the Google
App Engine, Android.
And one of them exciting was
Dart Hackathon, which was part
of a global Dart Hackathon
window.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: But you guys
organized the one, right?
BADRI KULKARNI: Yeah.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: You
were the organizer?
BADRI KULKARNI: Yes, yes.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Great.
BADRI KULKARNI: So these are
kind of the events that we had
in our Meetup, the last
one being a big one.
It's called DevFestX.
So DevFestX actually gave a
platform to all the developers
in and around Bangalore City
to come to the event and
interact with other people,
other developers which are of
like mind, and share
their knowledge.
So it was a great, great
experience, great event.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Were there
any wonderful collaborations
or products that came out of
that DevFestX experience?
BADRI KULKARNI: Yeah,
there are.
There are many.
I would like to take
an example of the
Dart Hackathon event.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN: Sure.
BADRI KULKARNI: So that was
first time that the developer
way of coding on that day,
because nobody has previously
done that, because it's a new
technology from Google.
So we had this Dart Hackathon.
Around 30 people came up.
30 participants--
members--
came up.
And on the spot, on the event
day, they collaborated.
They made themes among
themselves.
And at the end of the day, we
had around seven demos.
So that's pretty awesome.
So these guys are still
continuing on that, and trying
around these Dart
APIs, and giving
feedback to the Dart team.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: So it sounds
like you're involved
with all sorts of different
Google technologies.
BADRI KULKARNI: Yes.
Whatever you find it on
developers.google.com, we are there.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN: Now,
I heard that you're also
interested in Android.
Is that true?
Is that one of your--
BADRI KULKARNI: Yes.
I'm an Android developer.
So we do conduct of a lot of
events around Android.
So the one that I was mentioning
something,
DevFestX, there we
had a different
track for Android itself.
So what GDG gives all the
developers is a platform
wherein all the people who
are working on Google
technologies, directly or
indirectly, are actually
interested in working on these
technologies, can come and
join other people who are doing
the exact same thing.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: So you're
bringing people together.
So as an organizer, what
would you say?
If you're going to give advice
to other people out there who
were going to organize GDGs or
something, what kind of advice
would you give them?
BADRI KULKARNI: Yeah, what I'd
like to tell is, GDG is a
great platform.
So it will enable each and every
person who is really
interested in Google
technologies, it will help you
connect with other people
globally, not
only in your area.
It will help you to
connect globally.
And it's a great place to learn,
share, and work with
other people.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: This
goes back to what
we always talk about.
It's not underestimating the
power of a face-to-face
connection.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN: Right,
that high bandwidth.
It's much better than a bulletin
board, a forum, or an
email list, having people right
there in front of you.
BADRI KULKARNI: I would like
to tell one more example.
It's not like you have
to be in person.
We have had Meetups wherein some
of the people gave a talk
or something via Hangout.
So that's pretty awesome.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: So you're
looping people in, who can't
come in, through a Hangout.
BADRI KULKARNI: Yeah, true.
Yeah.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: OK.
Oh, that sounds-- is that
really effective?
Do you find that works
really well?
BADRI KULKARNI: Definitely,
yeah.
We have done that.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Yeah?
Great.
Well listen, thanks so
much for coming.
It was great talking to you.
Enjoy your conference.
We've got a couple more people
we're going to bring in here.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN:
Next country.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Next country,
yeah, exactly.
Next continent, actually.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN:
Wonderful.
Hi, what is your name?
AYGUL ZAGIDULLINA:
My name is Aygul.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: And
where are you from?
Tell us what you do.
AYGUL ZAGIDULLINA: I am
from Germany, and I'm
co-organizing two GTUGs.
In Germany, so GDG Stuttgart,
and in Russia, GDG Ufa.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: OK, so
you're an overachiever.
We got that, right?
But this isn't your
first I/O, is it?
AYGUL ZAGIDULLINA: No, it's not
my first I/O. I went for
the first time to Google
I/O last year.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN: And we
heard there was something
special about last year's
event for you.
AYGUL ZAGIDULLINA: Absolutely.
Actually, last Google I/O
was our honeymoon.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: And you met
your husband, and you guys
went to GTUG meetings
together, right?
That's why you got to know
each other, right?
AYGUL ZAGIDULLINA: Yeah.
Actually, we met first online.
And then one day we
went to Google--
the GDG organized Hackathon
in Stuttgart.
And we fell in love
with this concept.
And after three months, we
became co-organizers of the
GTUG, and organized after
that Android DevCamp
and all other events.
So it's real awesome.
We just fell in love
really quickly.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: So everybody
here is leaving with
hardware, you included.
Last year you left Google I/O
with a husband, right?
So this is like your big
anniversary party every year.
AYGUL ZAGIDULLINA: Absolutely.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK:
That's great.
So tell us a little more about
the events that you organize
and your GDG work in Germany.
AYGUL ZAGIDULLINA: Actually,
it's a really great
experience.
I can share it in Russia.
Last year we had all the Russian
and CIS countries
Hackathon on Google Chrome.
And we got an awesome
experience, awesome
opportunity to present our
projects on the main stage at
the Google Developer
Day in Moscow.
So it was a really amazing
experience.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN: What
were some of the
projects that got presented?
I'm curious what came
out of that.
AYGUL ZAGIDULLINA: It was Chrome
extensions with HTML5
apps, and they were really
on a high level.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: So what's
your favorite Google
technology that you
get to work with?
AYGUL ZAGIDULLINA: Actually,
Android.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Android?
AYGUL ZAGIDULLINA: Yes.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Are you an
Android developer as well?
AYGUL ZAGIDULLINA: I am
starting to develop.
So I am practicing right now.
And maybe next Google I/O,
I have something
to share with you.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: OK.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN: Is Android
popular within your
GDG groups as well?
AYGUL ZAGIDULLINA: Yes.
We actually made a survey, and
we just tried to find out
which technologies are really
popular in our countries.
And Android is absolutely like
first place, and then all
other technologies are
coming after that.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: So as an
organizer, what would you
advise other people out there
interested in organizing their
own GDG groups?
What would you advise
those guys to do?
What's the most important
thing?
AYGUL ZAGIDULLINA: Actually,
first of all, it's important
to make regular meetings with
all your guys and to know them
personally.
Not like developers, but also
like people, like a friend.
And my personal opinion is that
developers in one city
should know each other as
friends, not only as
professionals.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: So you're
talking about building
communities, right?
AYGUL ZAGIDULLINA:
Yes, absolutely.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Not just
a work relationship.
AYGUL ZAGIDULLINA: So we
are meeting each other.
We are going and playing
billiards.
We are going to the cinema.
So it's really--
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN: I was going
to say, going to bars
and pubs must be part
of it, then.
AYGUL ZAGIDULLINA: Right.
It should be beyond only
Hackathons, only Tech
talks, and so on.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: So are there
any collaborations that
you've seen come out of this?
People meet each other, and
then start working on apps
together, or start a business
or anything?
AYGUL ZAGIDULLINA: Yes.
Actually, my dream is that one
day we'll make a Tech Talk
from one of our apps or one of
our extensions, because we
have really talented people
in our GTUGs, and
they are really amazing.
They are really young, and they
have so much potential.
And I'm happy that GDGs and
Google's providing this
environment to actually
come them
together and build something.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK:
That's fabulous.
Excellent.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN:
I'm curious.
One last thing.
When you guys have meetings,
do you have set agendas or
particular speakers
on technologies?
AYGUL ZAGIDULLINA: It depends.
If it's Tech Talks, then we
have invited speakers.
But if it's Hackathons, there
will be just brainstorming,
and also applications
come out.
Just improvisation, it's also
part of our events.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: So let's
talk about Hackathons.
What do you do to organize
a Hackathon?
I mean, is there a lot of
preparation for that?
AYGUL ZAGIDULLINA: I mean,
a lot of preparation.
Google's already providing
us technology.
This is the main thing.
And everything will
come around.
So we are just, for example,
taking Google+ API and just
brainstorming.
And a lot of different ideas
coming out, and then we are
just forming teams.
And people are really
creative.
And this is actually
interesting, because they are
technical people, but they
actually can think
really out of box.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN:
That's fantastic.
Sounds like a great
environment for--
BRIAN FITZPATRICK:
That's great.
Well, we're glad to have
you back at I/O again.
AYGUL ZAGIDULLINA: Yeah,
thank you very much.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: And we'll see
you next year, I suppose.
AYGUL ZAGIDULLINA:
Yeah, see you.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: All
right, thanks a lot.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN: Roll
the wheel, next country.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: That's
great, yeah.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN:
That's great.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: So moving
next, we're going to South
America, I believe.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN:
Wonderful.
What is your name?
JUAN IRUNGARAY: I'm Juan from
Buenos Aires, Argentina.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: And Juan,
tell us what you do.
JUAN IRUNGARAY: Well,
I'm a GTUG manager.
I've been working at the Buenos
Aires GTUG for almost
two years now.
And it's really been
a great ride.
I mean, you get to know a lot
of interesting people.
You get to learn a lot,
and assist to
cool events like this.
So it's been really great.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN: Now, I
noticed you're calling it a
GTUG instead of GDG.
Can you give us the
story behind that?
JUAN IRUNGARAY: That's right.
So essentially the spirit
is the same.
We're just trying to appeal
to a broader audience.
So we just want everyone to know
that if you are a Google
technology user--
I mean, if you ever did a Google
search, you have an
Android phone, if you use
Google+ for your social
networking, there's people who
know about the topics.
There are a lot of people who
like to get together and share
what they know.
And we like people from diverse
backgrounds, from diverse--
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: So you're
doing something much bigger
than just developers, right?
This is really the user
element of it, right?
JUAN IRUNGARAY: Right.
So we've been working with
educators, with journalists.
We basically try to get everyone
to know what Google
tools are available and to make
the best use out of them.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN:
That's fantastic.
I think we're--
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: We'll--
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN: Go ahead.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: We're just
about out of time here.
Maybe one more quick question.
Quick piece of advice to anyone
out there who wants to
start their own GDG or GTUG?
JUAN IRUNGARAY: Just
look for us,
developers.google.com/groups.
There's a very active
community.
So you can either find a group
near you, or we can help you
start up a new group.
So just send us an email, and
we'll surely give you a hand.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN:
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK:
I appreciate it.
Excellent.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN: Yes.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: All right.
Thanks a lot.
We're going to turn it back
over to you guys.
And back to the conference.
See you in a bit.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN: Bye-bye.